hello and welcome to a special segment
of play for all GameSpot summer event
covering the latest and greatest of
video games
I'm Michael hi I'm and I am joined by an
illustrious guest Brian Fargo from in
exile and the director of wasteland 3
how are you doing Brian cool Brian you
have if folks don't know Brian has a
long history of developing video games
dating all the way back or not even all
the way back up but I guess the most
noticeable is the original fallout which
you are a producer on so you've been in
the industry for a very long time and
yeah wasteland 3 is the latest project
that you're on can you give folks a
brief overview if they're not familiar
with what wasteland 3 is the video game
business and I'm fortunate that I'm
still doing it after all these years our
first big headway back in the day was
the Bard's Tale and but we wanted to
follow it up with something different
and we and and that was the first
waistline game came out of 1988 and the
idea there one day I was a huge
post-apocalyptic fan loved the road
warrior was the movie I could just watch
it over and over and over again but it
could have been Planet of the Apes the
Omega man whatever it was I always loved
that category and what did he do
something that was more sort of
realistic we were simulating real world
things and licensed the system and we
also wanted to focus on like I'm sort of
different world building and morality
and difficult choices and which was sort
of fairly you know unique at the time
and again put the game out in 88 it
would do as a solid success won a bunch
of awards and then I wanted to make a
sequel I couldn't and that's how fallout
was born which was like okay fine I
can't do a sequel we'll go do something
else and then and then I left interplay
and then I was able to get the wasteland
rights back pitched it for many many
many years wasn't getting anywhere and
then I appealed to the fans via
Kickstarter and what was probably one of
the highlights of my career was the day
the bat product
got funded and then and then out here we
are way sundry so going from 2 to 2 3
here you don't necessarily need to have
the background with 2 but it certainly
helps so what is it fair to say that new
players can jump right into wasteland 3
with no prior knowledge of wasteland
sooo yes of course we would never but I
can't imagine that they need to be
wholly contained in themselves that
they're entertaining if you've never
played a waistline before if you have
played the other wasteland
there's a lot of inside humor others
things you would have a bit only you
would get and we'd like that and there
are there some parts we will feel more
meaningful if you knew the characters
before but it's absolutely not a
requisite to have to play those games
they're fully standing experiences yeah
I caught a few references in the beta
right off the bat which were which were
nice nods to wasteland 2 but like you
said it's not like critical to the story
but the things that are critical to
wasteland wasteland 1 came out before I
was born so what you guys did drop the
remaster so there there is that but
speaking about story critical stuff
choices and consequences are a huge part
of wasteland any C RPG of this style
there was even like there's stat checks
and the beta straight up so you get a
taste of that right away but with
wasteland 3 how are you evolving
morality systems because they have
changed so much over the years but how
is wasteland 3 adopting new styles of
choice consequences in morality perhaps
especially we we think that true
consequence and meaningful consequence
is what makes these worlds super
immersive and that's been the hallmark
of the series and with wasteland 3 more
than any other one we leaned into that
a big big way and you know part of our
dream here is to remind people why they
fell in love with post-apocalyptic RPGs
to begin with
whether it's wasteland or fallout they
always had those elements to it and it's
what made them special and a lot of it
comes down to paying off all of the edge
cases for what the players try and
having again having been meaningful it
isn't just the one author things you can
do that it might pay off that moment but
it might be ten hours later it might be
20 hours later and when I say pay off
that isn't necessarily a good thing
either yeah it could be bad you know
sort of depending on what you did but is
to make sure that the world is always
noticing what you're doing as a player
and to me that's where it starts to feel
real if you're doing these things and no
one ever comments on it or notices it I
think it starts to break down and so we
wanted to make sure that we were
constantly challenging ourselves to
Telegraph when the player was doing
things that were making things happen or
making things doing things that were not
happening either way there's too often
with these big role-playing games you
don't really appreciate the depth unless
you play it again and not many people
get a chance to play these big games
twice so we wanted to make sure that
people understood so I think we've done
a better job whereas in the past we were
probably too some now some of the things
we use as as to tell I'll give you some
examples right and I've talked before
which you know there's a paperboy and
he's always yelling out the headline so
as the rain to have worked their way
through the world neither doing
dastardly acts or good acts he's
commenting on it all the time so he's
letting people know you know the world
is seeing that it could be something
small where you you had Lucia join your
party and she's one of many NPCs that
could have joined your party and you're
walking through her old home and she
starts talking and pointing things out
in her house and that would only have
happened had she been in that party in
those little moments really bring it
alive and then you have larger moments
where you know you find refugees when
you get to the Ranger Citadel how do you
handle
you let them stay there and do you kick
them out and the world will react based
upon that single decision you made in
many many different ways when you get to
farad bribe Oh who's running the casino
you do you do you arrest him do you kill
him do you strike a deal with him so you
have any one of those options and then
what does law-enforcement think about
the fact that you struck a deal with him
for example so they're reacting so we're
really always twisting ourself up to
constantly get it where we hope the
player will be like I can't believe they
thought of that or they're getting
reacted to that to me that's my my
favorite parts of these and what's nice
is that you know what a lot of people
don't realize with games of this size
and scope is that no one person knows
everything that's in the game myself
included so at a certain level I'm able
to enjoy it so I'll try things and be
surprised at the payoff because as part
of our production process is that we we
have the writers and then we have the
level designers and we encourage the
level designers to to lean in on that
nuance and get those things in so they
put a whole layer of stuff to sort of be
if if then then then right and you get
these things and and they're just
wonderful
little spots of magic when they happen
in playing wasteland 2 and then here
with wasteland 3 I did feel like things
moved a little bit faster but also the
elements were a lot more apparent
because of how many different UI changes
there have been can you speak to some of
the changes you made with in terms of
how information is communicated to the
player and some of the UI overhauls that
kind of streamline things and make
things a little bit easier to engage
with well as you can tell from the beta
we tried very hard to make sure you have
all the information you needed to make
good decisions all the time because
without the information you can't make
technical decisions so again you know it
it's funny because it's been the common
theme of surfacing information whether
it was surfacing the narrative or we're
surfacing I'm standing here and if I if
I move here my chance
it is gonna change up or down based upon
these certain conditions and so that was
the most important part of our our you
live by the way since the beta backer
build we we've dive in more so we're
giving more shot variants so so for
example one of the things that people
were frustrated with this understanding
one foot up a bit away from a guy with a
shotgun how could I miss right well we
understand why that is right for because
you're supposed to be trade-offs of
weapons but now we said okay fine if
you're up close you can go for a spread
or you could go for a narrow shot
so we're actually we've added on to the
combat system move out there to give it
even more diversity in the weapons
because the most important thing is that
you whatever tactic you was working for
you and the first part of the game
cannot be working for you in the later
happen again we need to be constantly
adding different challenges and ways of
thinking you know what we have and this
comes into where you were talking about
setting things up like we have turrets
that the player can drop under the
battlefield so one guy could run and
drop these different turrets down and
then you should have commenced the
battle or we meet we have areas where
one guy can sneak around and then do
something and then kick off the battle
coming from the other side cool yeah I
definitely I definitely noticed it and I
think that that speaks to how you're
able to kind of maintain the
complexities of a C RPG but also make it
approachable is that something you're
conscious of when you're making
wasteland are you making this
approachable to maybe an audience that
isn't familiar with this style of game
yeah that's a great question because is
it's always been the the heart that you
know the real hardcore role-playing
games if it was up to them you know they
spend ten hours and in character
creation and and don't streamline a
single thing and so we are I think you
have to recognize you have to err more
towards the hardcore than you do with
the general people who don't play these
kind of things so we always when it
comes down to it if we're made to make a
decision we're gonna err towards that
you know you look at Pathfinder they're
they're character creation was insane
right and so but people they like that
so we recognize that so our version of
making it more approachable for example
would be that you when you start the
game you go into character creation or
just hey here's here's two pre-made
characters these ones will get you
through the game off you go right and
there's a percentage of the people that
don't they don't want to create a
character right there or maybe they want
to get more information about what's
important and then they'll go create the
character and then we allow you to
respec when you get to ranger citadel
anyway you can create your own party
there so I think that's the kind of
decision we make that is like the best
of all worlds but in generally we're
very cognizant of not giving up anything
for the hard board to make it quote
approachable all right now to shift
gears a little bit in terms of the
conversation in exile was acquired by
Microsoft in 2018 is one of the many big
deals that Microsoft made in terms of
building up their their a studio
presence for game development so two
sides of this question how has the
acquisition changed things for in exile
and how has that been reflected in
wasteland 3 the the acquisition has been
great for us I mean we we spent a lot of
great amount of our time pitching
whether it was published doors or you're
pitching to the public with crowdfunding
and chasing it and then and all the
steps along the way to prove that you're
sort of doing the things that you said
so now a hundred percent of our job is
on creativity and then just the
production of making the game and it is
it's a rare thing to be able to get that
in addition they've you know we always
knew the certain areas of the company
that we really could use more people
whether it was more animators audio
engineer animation engineer whatever
these different roles were I always like
having a band we knew we didn't have a
bass player what we did our best and so
I think that for us I think in exile has
done a great job with very little by and
large I see this as an opportunity to
really allow us to shy
like we never have before wastelands
just the tip of the iceberg because we
were well into production when they came
along but even that the the additional
time that we've gotten has made the game
so much better I was having a call at
Microsoft last week I said you know the
amount of comments that I get in would
get addressed and that's just me
everybody else has their own there's
probably a thousand things that got
adjusted and changed and improved just
by moving something out by 60 days and
giving you said extra time to do it so
as you think forward from the game was
still going to be last year and they're
like no let's let what would you do if
you want if you you know have more time
and money we knew what we wanted to do
and we couldn't wait right and we're
able to do all those different things
and so in terms of its we know that
optimization has to be good loading
times have to be good walk animations
either looks smooth the music needs to
dock at the appropriate times we need to
Telegraph certain things in the game so
that they're clear adding more weapon as
you know what I was talking earlier
about giving more weapon control getting
all the feedback from the beta testers
and making sure it gets addressed it's
literally thousands of things and always
in the business when you look at the
great developers whether it's Rockstar
or blizzard you know what is the thing
they always have in common they get a
lot of time you know and so even a
little bit of extra time goes a long way
and a lot of people I don't think
realize how 90 days can make the
difference between just a an A and a B
so that that has been the biggest change
for the company I want to thank you for
taking the time to speak with us I know
that game development is a it's a long
journey and there's a lot of work ahead
of you but yeah this has been very
insightful so thanks Brian cool cool and
it's fun to talk about the old times
from time to time
oh sorry but but now I'm super no matter
how long I've been doing this for I'm
like not jaded at all like I can't wait
to get wasteland into people's hands I
love the reaction I do this for the
reaction that's the fun part right I
mean we've got you we all work so hard
because we want to entertain people and
oh that was a great experience and so
I'm feeling pretty good about this one
and I'm really looking forward to the
feedback sweet all right there you have
it folks
wasteland 3 coming out later this year
on PC and Xbox one and all of you thank
you so much for tuning in and watching
we have so much more coverage here at
GameSpot for play for all remember that
we're doing this for the rest of the
month we're trying to raise funds for
Copa 19 relief or having live streams
every every day and we have developer
interviews we got exclusive gameplay all
sorts of good stuff for the coming weeks
so please stay tuned the game spot and
we'll see you later
[Music]